de prononcer quelques paroles de
bienvenue
vous connaissez le sujet la stabilité
internationale et cyber sécurité
conflits régionaux les relations
commerciales
nous avons abordé notre coopération en
arctique je vous en prie vos questions
beach monde entier vous nous parler des
sujets évoqués en détail aujourd'hui
notamment à l'ukraine tout là quel
contexte avez vous discuté de l'ukraine
de la situation dans la zone basse de la
possibilité de l'adhésion de l'ukraine
le temps et il avait de grandes attentes
relatives au retour des ambassadeurs par
exemple monsieur ou shakhova dit que ce
serait possible
merci oui concernant le retour des
ambassadeurs à leur place habituelle de
travail à moscou et washington
nous nous sommes convenus que cette
question est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
l'horreur ambassadeurs respectifs demain
ou après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain qui vont entamer des
consultations sur l'ensemble de notre
interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes
j'ai eu l'impression que les deux
parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions concernant l'ukraine hui nous
avons abordé ce sujet je ne peux pas
dire que très en détail mais j'ai
compris que le président byden est
d'accord que la base de ce règlement en
ukraine dans l'est de l'ukraine par par
les discussions nous avons abordé
quelques détails également du retour de
l'ukraine vers l'automne et tartas s'il
vous plaît
vous avez dit que l'un des sujets
simples et la stabilité stratégique à
pourriez vous parler plus en détail des
décisions dans ce domaine serait qu'un
type de prise la russie les etats-unis
vont-ils reprendre vous relancer les
négociations concernant la stabilité
stratégique et le désarmement
s'agit-il de l'application des traités
ou la ceinture d'un nouvel accord les
états unis et la fédération de russie
assume une responsabilité particulière
pour la stabilité stratégique dans le
monde
nous sommes les deux grandes puissances
nucléaires de par le nombre de têtes et
de vecteurs et de par le niveau et le
niveau moderne des armes que nous
possédons nous assumons cette
responsabilité et je crois que tout le
monde comprend que le président wade n a
pris une décision responsable qui
concerne la prolongation de l'accord a
new start
bien sûr la question se pose qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire ensuite nous nous sommes
convenus de la poursuite des
consultations au niveau des ministères
sous l'égide du département d'état et du
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
au niveau de travail et nous avons
décidé de
nous convenir sur le personnel de ces
négociations
ici on n'amène merci de m'avoir donné la
parole y aura tout d'abord parler en
général de cette réunion ça fait le
président en bas d'un jeu s'est déroulé
de manière constructive
où est-il la deuxième question et
concernant les huits vers attaque avez
vous évoqué cette question avez vous
pris un engagement dans le domaine je te
la cybercité l'évaluation général
j'estime qu'il n'y a eu pas d'hostilité
oui bien sûr discussions revêtaient la
nature assez principale il ya des
divergences dans nos évaluations mais
des deux parties nous avons fait preuve
de la volonté de nous comprendre et de
chercher les points de convergence ce
dialogue était assez constructif
concernant la cybersécurité nous nous
sommes convenus du fait que nous allons
commencer des consultations à mon avis
c'est très important
concernant la responsabilité assumée
je vous informe ce sont les choses
qui sont évidentes est connu pour le
grand public les sources américaines
je crains de confondre peut-être leur
saper la scion et leur nom donc les
sources et américaines estiment que la
grande le grand nombre la majeure partie
des cyber attaques viennent du
territoire américain
deuxième place revient au canada ensuite
deux pays de l'amérique latine et la
grande bretagne concernant le territoire
russe qui est l'origine des
cyberattaques ne figure pas dans cette
liste
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose au cours de 2020 nous avons reçu
dix demandes de la part de la partie
américaine qui concernait les cyber
attaques comme quoi les sites américains
ont été attaqués depuis le territoire
russe et de demandes cette année si nous
avons donné des réponses adressées à des
collègues américains
deux seins par la partie russe a dépêché
cinq demandes et cette année 6,35
demande mais pour le moment nous n'avons
aucune réponse
il y a donc du pain sur la planche et la
question devrait assumer cette
responsabilité
c'est la question des négociations on va
entamer ses consultations et nous
estimons que ce secteur de cyber
sécurité est très important partout dans
le monde pour les états unis en
particulier et pour la fédération de
russie également par exemple nos
nous savons qu'il ya eu des cyber
attaques dirigées contre une société et
gazière aux états unis et qui a dû payer
à des personnes qui ont fait chanter
cette entreprise 5 millions de dollars
une partie de cette somme a été
remboursée mais la russie n'y est pour
rien nous sommes confrontés également
assez menace par exemple le système de
santé public d'une région du hand
régions russes a été cible de ces
attaques
et ce travail et est coordonné depuis le
territoire américain
je ne pense pas que les autorités
américaines ont quelques intérêts dans
ces attaques
il faut donc abandonné toutes sortes d'
intox
au niveau d'experts nous avons besoin de
travailler dans les intérêts des états
unis et de la fédération de russie qui
est nous nous sommes convenus et nous y
sommes prêts la chaîne arte les micros
adaptés
s'il vous plaît prenez le micro merci
beaucoup d'études de revenir sur ma
question la deuxième partie de ma
question avez-vous pris des engagements
pour mettre fin aux menaces adressées à
l'ukraine à vous savez qu'il y a eu des
exercices militaires organisés par la
fédération de russie à la deuxième
partie de ma question avez vous pris l
engagement de mettre fin aux attaques
contre l'opposition
je n'ai pas entendu cette partie est
question peut-être ce n'étaient pas
traduits
concernant nos engagements vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine
nous avons un seul engagement contribuer
à la réalisation des accords de mise
comme si que la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire on va entamer cette
voie sans aucun doute je porte votre
attention sur le fait que novembre
dernier la délégation ukrainienne nous a
adressé ses estimations sur sa leur
vision des accords de minsk
il parle de l'intégration politique du
temps basse dans le système politique
ukrainien et dans la constitution
ukrainienne a donc il faut apporter des
amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne
et deuxième chose c'est que les
frontières entre la russie et l'ukraine
qui passe par le donbass vont être
occupés par les gardes frontières
ukrainiens lendemain des élections
ukrainiennes qu'est-ce que l'ukraine
propose donc le premier pas c'est de
faire rentrer les tropiques hongyan
vers leur base habituelle c'est-à-dire
entrer dans le donbass ensuite fermer
les frontières et troisième chose tenir
les élections
trois mois après ces deux démarches une
liste et on on n'a pas besoin d'être
juriste pour comprendre que c'est
contraire aux accords de minsk et je
pense que la réponse de la russie est
évidente concernant les exercices
militaires ces exercices ont lieu sur
notre propre territoire à l'instar des
états unis qui font leurs exercices
militaires sur leur propre territoire
malheureusement nos amis américains le
fond près des frontières russes
donc c'est la partie russe qui est
préoccupé par ces agissements des
troupes américaines mais c'est aussi un
sujet des négociations concernant notre
proposition russe et le citoyen dont
vous parlez est la première chose
cette personne savait qu'ils aient des
rôles aux lois qui sont en vigueur en
russie puisque il était condamné par
sursis et donc ils ont il a ignoré ces
exigences des lois il est parti dans un
autre pays
une fois de retour de l'hôpital
et quand il a mis en ligne ces vidéos
sur internet
alors cette loi devrait être respectée
et donc il était recherché
il était de retour en russie et je crois
qu'il avait pris conscience qu'ils
seraient interpellés
alors concernant ces personnes comme
celui ci concernant toutes les personnes
qui sont opposés à aux autorités russes
pour le moment si le format de cette
conférence de presse ne permet pas de le
dire en détail mais je veux vous dire
très simplement et vous allez comprendre
et vous pouvez en informer votre public
les etats unis d'amérique
honte annoncé que la russie est
l'adversaire l'ennemi des états unis le
concret le fait en deux en 2017
la législation américaine contient des
dispositions conquois les états unis
devraient soutenir la démocratie en
russie et les organisations politiques
en russie
c'est la loi américaine qui le dit alors
on se pose la question si le récit c'est
l'ennemi
quels sont les organisations politiques
vont être soutenus par les états unis
sur le territoire us je pense que ce ne
sont pas les organisations politiques et
qui renforce la fédération de russie
mais qui contiennent la russie ça c'est
la déclaration officielle
c'est l'objectif des états unis ce sont
les organisations et les personnes qui
contribuent à la politique américaine et
sur le territoire russe
comment réagir donc de notre côté et je
crois que
on comprend très bien que nous devrions
être méfiant mais réagir dans le
contexte de la loi russe la parole à
paris bim s'il vous plaît pas mais les à
robin l'agencé guetteur cas je voudrais
poursuivre ce sujet les etats-unis
parlent toujours des prisonniers
politiques
un prétendu un peu psy mais le sujet de
ne pas le nier at-il été évoqué lors de
vos négociations et de quelle manière
est une autre question importante
nous voyons qu'il ya une nouvelle étape
des relations russo américaines qui a
commencé au début de la présidence du
président baden c'est à dire que le
président d'en avant dé le sujet des
droits de l'homme et des personnes qui
sont liées à cette question en la feda
sont aussi nous en avons parlé à son
initiative ça ses premiers points
le deuxième point sur les
déclarations fracassantes tout le monde
français ensuite le président madame
avait appelé cette expliquer son
explication m'a satisfait il a proposé
de se retrouver c'est son initiative
nous nous sommes retrouvés et encore une
fois cette conversation a été donc ce
genre de discussions doivent avoir entre
tous les dirigeants entre cadieux
ensuite coussins les accusations son
prédécesseur et donc le président nike a
décidé de répondre de cette façon vous
savez en principe tout ce qui se produit
dans nos pays d'une façon engage la
responsabilité de la direction politique
et tu es première personne de l'état sur
responsable tic
regardez dans les rues aux états unis
tous les jours il ya des marques et
notamment de dirigeants d'organisations
politiques
on croise les gens on les tue le jeu me
rappelle justement dadkhah comme ça où
une femme sort d'une voiture elle se
fait assassiner tout de suite d'une
balle dans le dos prenons l'afghanistan
d'un coût 120 personnes assassinées en
pleine hausse par exemple supposons que
ce fait une erreur ça arrive les erreurs
mais les enquêtes
faites vous montrer que les tirs menés
depuis des drones et des hélicoptères
avaient directement visé des civils qui
porte la responsabilité qui assume la
responsabilité de c2c de ces crimes
en ce qui concerne les droits de l'homme
je continue à travailler
il ya des choses qui ne respectent ni
les lois américaines ni les principes
des droits de l'homme il ya guantanamo
il ya les prisons de la cia ou les
tortures ont été appliquées
et ça c'est quoi ces les droits de
l'homme peut-être je pense que non est
ce que quelqu'un ici dans la salle sera
prêt à dire que c'est la défense des
droits de l'homme ces prisons donc c'est
la politique réelle et nous partons de
la pratique
nous considérons que de telles choses
existent et donc nous nous adaptons
notre position et donc les gens qui
reçoivent de l'argent de l'étranger pour
défendre les intérêts de ceux qui les
paient doivent assumer leurs
responsabilités la chaîne arte castillet
j'ai une question sur l'arctique
vous avez dit que je vous avais évoqué
ce sujet les états unis et depuis
longtemps et que c'est la réussite d'une
militarisation de l'arctique et ses
alliés leurs alliés autre exemple
récemment le secrétaire blinken a dit a
exprimé ses préoccupations par les actes
de l'état russe en a fait effectivement
nous avons abordé ce thème dans la
réunion élargie et en détail
c'est un sujet important et concernant
l'article
d'une manière générale et en particulier
de l'itinéraire de nord
nous en avons parlé parce que c'est une
question régionale c'est une question
économique important de cette
préoccupation de la partie américaine
entrepôt de là
militarisation ne repose sur absolument
rien je ne faisons rien de ce qui avait
été fait par exemple nous simplement
nous resterons les infrastructures de
l'époque il ya des infrastructures
militaires il ya des infrastructures de
la garde
méthon
sur la scène pourtant il ya des
structures de sauvetage si quelqu'un est
en péril en mer par exemple et j'ai dit
à nos collègues que je ne vois ici aucun
motif de préoccupation et que au
contraire je pense que nous pouvons
travailler nous devons travailler
ensemble la russie les états-unis sont
font partie des huit pays membres du
conseil de l'arctique et cette année la
russie assume la présidence de ce
conseil de l'arctique
par exemple vous savez que entre
l'alaska et la tchoukotka yann le
célèbre détroit de béring d'un côté
c'est la russie de l'autre côté c'est
les états unis et cela fait que nous
devons unir nos efforts en ce qui
concerne l'utilisation de l'itinéraire
du grand nord elle doit répondre aux
deux axes et à l'acte sur la navigation
méritiez maritime et le code arctique
qui se compose de différents textes
ratifiés en 2017 j'ai attiré l'attention
de nos partenaires sur le fait que nous
la russie
nous avons l'intention de nous en tenir
pleinement aux normes de droit en cela
nous n'avons jamais rien enfreint nous
sommes prêts à coopérer avec tous les
pays et toutes les entreprises qui
travaillent à la conquête de grand nord
par exemple il ya les questions de
navigation qui dure six mois et sud de
l'année et avec le réchauffement
climatique ça devrait s'étendre à
l'ensemble de l'année donc il ya
notamment des
brise-glace atomique aujourd'hui qui
sont aisés et donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
une demande si nous en construisons
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya une demande
et le droit maritime international fait
qu' il stipule leur régime des eaux
internationales notamment les eaux
interne
les maires interne les eaux
territoriales les eaux limitrophes
les zone économique franche et la haute
mer rue c'est à dire les maires interne
ce son qui se trouve à l'intérieur d'un
territoire national il ya les eaux
territoriales à 12000 du littoral et les
pays sur les mers intérieures doivent
assurer un passage libre y compris pour
les navires militaires
en ce qui concerne les mères il y a là
un régime particulier les pays ne sont
pas obligés de fournir des documents ou
des droits particuliers
si je me souviens bien ya cinq maires
concernés ici par exemple s'il ya le le
détroit tout ça représente 965 mine de
littoral mais c'est notre droit
souverain de laisser passer ou de ne pas
laisser passer mais nous n'habitons pas
de ce droit
nous fournissons un droit d'accès il ya
eu des demandes de passage l'an dernier
est pour l'essentiel c'était des bateaux
battant pavillon russe
nos services de contrôle se réfère au
code article
si lui-même défini clairement les
exigences pour chaque catégorie de
navires et nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des pays qui peuvent être
concernées et nous allons travailler
ensemble pour résoudre toutes les
questions passionnés des questions qui
ont besoin encore de résolution mais je
suis convaincu que nous trouverons des
solutions
je ne vois aucun problème ici qui ne
puisse être résolu et la chaîne ntv
herrada sinaloa vaut la parole bonjour
monsieur faustin de relations ou de
relations normales entre la russie et
les etats unis ont toujours été le gage
de la stabilité globale et mettant les
relations sont telles que vous avez dit
vide d'aden à partager votre avis
maintenant vous dites qu'il ya des
lignes rouges pour la russie on voit que
les américains ont touché leur ligne
rouge
est ce que vous avez réussi convenir à
cette décision de ne pas franchir ces
lignes rouges je peux vous dire que dans
l'ensemble nous comprenons de quoi nous
n'ont pas nos partenaires américains ils
comprennent de quoi nous parlons quand
il s'agit des lignes rouges
mais je vous dis franchement
aller loin en détail sur ses lignes
rouges
non là on n'a pas encore été à ce
moment-là ce que je veux dire c'est que
nous sommes mis d'accord pour travailler
en matière de cybersécurité de stabilité
stratégique et au cours de ces
consultations
de même que le niveau de l'article par
exemple il doit y avoir dans des
discussions et je pense que nous
parviendrons à des accords maintenant et
bisenius nos collègues américains avant
la parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président joe biden dit à maintes
reprises qu'il allait répondre à des
cyberattaques en provenance de la russie
qu'est-ce qui a dit précisément des
ménages peut être qu est-ce que les
états unis vont ils faire c'est la
russie ne cesse pas ces cyberattaques et
une autre question relative à alex et
navalni son fonds de anti corruption a
été qualifiée dans les actions
extrémistes et tous les participants ne
peuvent pas être et le pourquoi avez
vous peur de cela encore une fois que je
respecte je répète ce que j'ai déjà dit
sûr à propos des agents de l'étranger et
des gens qui se positionne comme
opposition systématique j'ai répondu
déjà à votre collègue c'est cnn c'est ça
admettons je pense que c'est une loi
d'urgence et guérir qu'il faut répondre
aussi à votre question donc je répète
encore une fois les ils ont dit qu'ils
allaient soutenir cette organisation
politique en russie
en même temps ils ont déclaré que la
fédération de russie était l'ennemi et
qu'il ferait en sorte de contenir le
développement de la question quels sont
les organisations politiques de la
communauté internationale et qui doivent
soutenir ces organisations d'opposition
et les financer déjà dans les années 30
les états unis avaient qualifié
certaines organisations des agents de
l'étranger
et cette déclaration d'organes
organisations étrangères continuent de
travailler des organisations extremis là
c'est autre chose et les organisations
dont vous parlez on appelait ouvertement
à faire des manifestations de masse des
désordres de masse en russie impliquer
des mineurs et ça c'est interdit par la
loi russe
ils ont donné des instructions comment
préparer des cocktails molotov par
exemple les utiliser contre les forces
de l'ordre et ils ont publié des données
de pression
les etats-unis ont été confrontés
récemment des événements graves après le
meurtre d'un afro-américain leur dernier
donc il ya eu tout un mouvement
hellemmes kishi s'est mis en place je
vais pas commenter
simplement ce que je veux dire c'est que
ce que nous avons vu ces saccages ces
infractions à la loi et c'est nous c'est
ce que notre compassion envers les
américains mais nous ne voulons pas
qu'une telle chose se produise dans
notre pays et nous ferons tout pour
empêcher que cela se produise ici c'est
pas une question de craindre de ne pas
craindre donné le micro
s'il vous plaît mais vous n'avez pas
répondu et monsieur tu ne regardes et
l'ensemble de vos aux adversaires
politiques sont soit tués soit envoyée
en prison
n'est ce pas signale qu'elle n'a pas de
son côté tué quelqu'un emprisonné
quelqu'un ces personnes sont entrés dans
le concret américain avec des rayons
disques revendications politiques
il y a quatre cents personnes qui sont
menacées par la prison jusqu'à 20 au 25
ans qui sont déclarés terroriste interne
ils sont aucune accusé par des crimes et
autres crimes à 70 ont été interpellés
tout de suite et 30 parmi eux sont
toujours dans la prison
pour quelle raison on ne comprend pas
très bien puisque les autorités des
états ne nous informe pas
quelques personnes ont été tuées et une
femme
a été directement un fusible tués par
balles et par un policier donc ça se
passe dans de nombreux pays et je
souligne encore une fois il y a de la
compassion de notre part envers les
américains mais nous ne voulons pas que
ça se passe en russie encore à quelques
questions
la roue les huit tiers avait réussi à
terminer un accord avec les américains
sur le retour des russes a impressionné
aux états unis puis nous en avons parlé
le président wade n a soulevé cette
question
il a parlé des prisonniers américains
qui se trouvent dans les prisons russes
nous en avons parlé et nous pouvons
trouver un compromis le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères et le
département d'état et vont travailler
une question de la chaîne rossiya
bonjour mikhail antonov la chaîne
rossiya vous avez dit que vous avez
évoqué le commerce avec le président
baden as les milieux d'affaires à des
deux pays sont intéressés par le
développement qui sont les perspectives
selon vous cela ne dépend pas de nous
cela dépend de la partie américaine non
ne déclarant aucune sanction des
restrictions après
[Musique]
l'arrivée de ces restrictions dans le
commerce les états unis ont perdu autant
que la russie bien sûr cela a eu un
impact sur notre développement en partie
et les etats unis ont en quelque sorte
contenu la russie mais il y a rien de
critique là dessus c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose cela concerne
l'intérêt des entreprises américaines
200 personnes ont été présents au forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg
c'était la plus grande délégation
délégations étrangères et suite à des
restrictions pour les entreprises
américaines certaines entreprises
américaines haute donc laisser
abandonner le marché russe à quoi ça
sert et il n'y a aucun sasseville sans
s'épuiser
il n'y a que des parts nos échanges
commerciaux s'élève à 28 milliards de
dollars
et durant le premier trimestre trimestre
et l'inconnu la hausse de 16 5% et on en
a parlé
quelques questions de ceux de ce côté et
de l'autre côté sur son prix c'est la
jeune fille qui va poser la question
merci beaucoup monsieur le président un
pour cette opportunité de vous poser la
question le président baden à l'époque
il était vice président il l' a dit qu'
il l'a vous à regarder
oui dans les yeux elle n'a pas vu dames
et vous avez répondu cela veut dire que
nous entendons bien vous avez à regarder
directement dans ses yeux qu'est ce que
vous avez vu dans ses yeux
avez vous vu quelqu'un avec qui vous
pourriez conférer et dit monsieur le
président en baisse dans ce qu'il vous a
invité à venir à la maison blanche le
président bédié ne m'a pas évités et
chez lui pour le moment je n'ai pas à
n'a pas adressé cette invitation au
président américain que ce que je crois
que il y à des circonstances et qui
doivent être réunies pour ces visites
concernant ne regarder dans les yeux
pour voir l'âme de cette personne je
l'entends non pas pour la première fois
puis je suis pas ce que ça peut arriver
mais si vous me demandez mon avis sur le
président baden davies je crois que
c'est une personne pondéré constructive
très expérimenté ça se voit tout de
suite il est s'est souvenu de sa famille
un peu il a parlé un peu de des paroles
de sa mère
ce sont des choses à première vue qui ne
sont pas importantes mais cela montre
que
c'est une personne de qualité cela
montre ses qualités morales et cela
provoque de la sympathie jeu j'ai un peu
l'impression qu'on a abordé le même
langage et nous n'avons pas besoin de
regarder dans les yeux
nous protégeons les intérêts de 10 de
nos nations de nos peuples et c'est très
pratique entrée jose au prix kommersant
monsieur poutine quand même à l'issue de
ce sommet avez-vous de nouvelles
illusions
je n'ai aucune illusion ancien même
pourquoi par les désillusions
non je n'ai pas dit lui d'illusions ce
n'est pas le cas encore une question
allez-y vous avez le micro
vous évoquez le sujet des changements
climatiques et la deuxième question
concernant les médias américains
heureusement vous avez accordé une
grande interview à nbc
vous croyez que c'est juste que vous
accordez une interview au média
américain alors que les présidents
américains d'accor pas d'interviews aux
médias et selon vous est ce que ces
interviews on n'aime pas positive mais
concernant certaines attaques
je veux dire que c'est la pratique des
relations internationales aujourd'hui
rien à faire j'y suis habitué on vit
avec depuis des décennies concernant les
interviews cela est décidée par des
responsables d'un pays concret si un
dirigeant veut parler à une autre nation
on essaie de le faire et mes interviews
à la presse américaine ont cet objectif
concernant les activités de nos médias
les médias russes
en général le président banda a parlé de
l'activité de la chaîne liberté aux
biens europe libre en russie qui était
déclarée à jambles étrangers en russie
j'ai l'impression que les membres de la
délégation américaine ne connaissent pas
très bien cette chaîne
mais et je parle de l'histoire à chatou
des écoutes nick qui ont été privé
d'accréditation et c'était la meilleure
rotation de la part de la russie tandis
que roche auto day remplissent toutes
les exigences des autorités américaines
sur le territoire américain
quoique il ya toutes sortes d'obstacles
de nature financière par exemple nous
n'avons pas cette sorte de problèmes et
les médias américaines ne respecte
pleinement les exigences des autorités
russes quand même mais j'espère qu'on va
réussir grâce à notre ministère des
affaires étrangères de le faire de l'ina
polanski à la chaîne euronews
nous avons dieu que vous avez serré la
main chang byden début de votre réunion
mais vous que c'était à plat et les
réalistes de à passer une nouvelle étape
des relations des relations claires et
transparentes
ce qu'est que les deux partis chercher
côté léon tolstoï et disait que dans la
vie il n'ya pas de bonheur y'a que des
clercs et qui sont très précieux
justement dans cette situation on peut
pas parler de la confiance
en famille mais il y a des indices des
éclairs qui ont été manifestées et c'est
bien je vous en prie vous avez le micro
vous voulez le 2ème micro est vendue la
go est la chaîne pervyi kanal le sujet
de couronnes et les russes c'est un des
sujets clés partout dans le monde avait
voulu évoquer ce sujet lors du sommet
avec le président américain
nous ferons un type quelles sont les
perspectives de coopération avec les
états unis afin de vaincre le chrono
virus a peut-être s'agit-il de la
reconnaissance des vaccins oui nous
avons évoqué ce sujet très en bref comme
vous le savez même sous l'administration
précédente américaine nous avons réagi à
la demande de la partie américaine
nous avons envoyé le matériel médical
pour aider les états unis d'amérique hui
les états unis c'est un pays puissant
mais mais qu'ils avaient besoin des
respirateurs et on l'a envoyée
gratuitement et nous sommes prêts à la
coopération dans ce secteur mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas parlé en
détail de ce sujet avec avec le
président entend qu'on a vu une
détérioration
après votre sommeil est un des facteurs
qui permettent de d'espérer que cela ces
situations ne se répétera pas on a déjà
touché les fonds non difficile de vous
répondre
toutes les actions qui ont été
manifestées
par le contraire américain je ne sais
pas qu'est ce que le congrès américain
va inventer encore je ne sais pas je
vous en prie exemple qu'un mode comme sk
pravda je ne sais pas si vous êtes au
courant ou non joe boyd des bottines en
caoutchouc à distribuer quel est le
résultat du sommet entre vous et
monsieur ben laden est la deuxième
question les américains avant de venir à
genève se disaient qu'ils allaient faire
pression sur la russie vous
personnellement avez-vous ressenti cette
pression et comment avez-vous fait face
à cette pression est là qui sont clés
qui est je crois être intéressant pour
l'heure aussi qu'est-ce que vous
monsieur poutine a fait à genève et je
pense que je pense que c'est suspense
aussi aucune pression je n'ai pas
ressenti aucune pression
nous n'avons pas apporté d'autres sujets
qui ont été prévus et des deux parties
il n'y a aucune pression c'est pas
l'objectif de notre rencontre et quel
était le score de notre rencontre avant
notre rencontre le président à baden
disait que ce n'est pas une compétition
sportive et je suis d'accord avec lui
non il n'y a aucun score ce dialogue
était assez méticuleux concret
détaillé et qui se passait en ambiance
qui donné l'espérance d'obtenir des
résultats
bbc news ce jose un prix aussi bas
bbc news bbc
stabilini picazo mais atteignent ce
récit non nasa petit chemin à l'accident
ce qu'on croit que à l'imprévisibilité
c'est les traits caractéristiques pour
la politique extérieure de la russie
êtes vous prêt à abandonner cette
imprévisibilité dans votre politique
pour améliorer les relations mais vous
savez mélangez tout et vous avez
beaucoup réussi je vous envie
pour répondre la première partie de
votre question vous dit tant qu'à
l'occident on dit que la politique russe
est imprévisible
alors je vous renvoie le ballon par
exemple l'accord abm a c'est un accord
très prévisible pourquoi le détruire
pourquoi sortir de l'accord inf 1 est ce
que c'est de la stabilité la sortie de
l'accord consacré au ciel ouvert presque
rien ne reste dieu merci le président
biden a décidé de prolonger le traité
new start c'était très raisonnable pour
les cinq ans à venir
si on parle de l'ukraine
un côté star en ukraine le président
ianoukovitch a accepté toutes les
revendications de l'opposition
et il était prête à parts à partir mais
il a fallu deux organiser un coup d'état
en ukraine
et vous croyez que nous sommes
imprévisibles non je ne pense pas à mon
avis nous sommes à des coins et nos
réagissons aux menaces qui se présente
et je crois que pour rendre la situation
stable il faut parler des règles de
conduite c'est la stabilité
internationale c'est la cybersécurité ce
sont les questions des conflits
régionaux et je crois que ce sont les
sujets qui peuvent être obligé des
négociations et qui peuvent donner des
résultats
merci
on va bientôt chanter des chansons là je
comprends pas très bien
vos collègues étrangers allaient donnant
la parole à quelqu'un parmi les
étrangers a lésé bloomberg
la dernière question le maire tenue ça
il est rare qu'ils peuvent mais ce putin
en 2016 après le sommet avec très peu de
nouvelles sanctions américaines et est
rapidement imposé aujourd'hui lors des
négociations avec vos reçu des
assurances de monsieur ben laden que les
états unis ne vont pas imposer de
nouvelles sanctions
et quant aux résultats que vous avez
évoqué qu'il y a des désespoirs qu'il ya
surtout de confiance
avez-vous du point de vue de visibilité
des accords qui existent avez-vous
maintenant plus de confiance
estimez vous qu'il est le faire a
effectivement parce que je crois que
maintenant les toutes les institutions
se tiennent aux états unis la politique
de joe biden il ya plus de solidarité et
quand consultation sur les craintes par
exemple où la cybersécurité donc des
groupes de travail seront
créer c'est ça et avez vous marquez de
montrouge
en ce qui nous sommes cellino je lui ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
cette convention est l'appareil quand on
discute sur les principaux axes de
discussion c'est pas la peine de se
frayer des uns des autres
si les gens se rencontrent pour discuter
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire sinon ça
sert à rien de se voir en ce qui
concerne les sanctions oui y ait des
restrictions sur le plan économique j'ai
déjà dit nous connaissons les humeurs
politiques en interne aux états unis
mais nous ne pouvons pas nous prendre
tout ce qui se passe là bas donc il y à
des adversaires au développement des
relations avec les états unis
il yad'autres des partisans aussi c'est
difficile de dire qui
et plus important ici mais si après
notre rencontre des mesures centre
entreprises notamment ceux que vous avez
évoqué après 2016 ça veut dire que ce
serait à nouveau une opportunité manquée
maintenant c'est effectivement la
dernière question journaliste canadienne
le seul président un merci beaucoup
tam a réitéré ce qu'offre la radio
canada vous avez dit à mes collègues que
vous attendez là interprétation
l'interprétation
je sais pas quelle chaîne branches et là
j'ai pas de traduction 1 2 3 il faut
trouver la bonne chaîne
j'entends rien
[Musique]
attendez une seconde
excusez moi donc le son c'est bon
répéter s'il vous plaît 13 c'est la
radio canada à moscou vous avez dit à
mes collègues a voulu des questions aux
nets soit posée j'ai une question qui a
été posée par ma fille qui a 9 ans elle
m'a demandé c'est quoi que ce soit mais
pourquoi ce sommet est tellement
importante qu'elle soit votre réponse à
une fille âgée de 9 ans pourquoi les
relations entre la russie les usa sont
tellement compliqués moi aussi je
voudrais le savoir pourquoi le jeu ne
peuvent pas participer à des
protestations
oui c'est bien que votre fille qui a 9
ans s'intéresse à ces questions la
réponse est simple
ce qu'il faut regarder tout seul il faut
le dites à votre enfant à regarder comme
le monde comme il est beau regarde et
les dirigeants de ces deux pays qui sont
les deux plus grandes puissances
intéressant pour que le monde soit plus
sûre plus fiables soient connaissent une
plus grande prospérité pour l'ensemble
des habitants de notre planète ils vont
parler de questions qui sont liées à des
armes qui sont terribles et qu'il faut
limiter et pour lesquels il faut
élaborer des règles comme vivant il
parlait de la protection de
l'environnement pour que les rivières
pour que les moeurs octobre pour qu'il
n'y ait pas d'inondations qu'il n'y ait
pas de sécheresse qu'il y ait
suffisamment de denrées alimentaires
pour l'ensemble de la population de la
terre
ils vont parler de questions de santé
publique pour que justement les enfants
vont grandir pour qu'ils ne soient pas
malades pour qu'ils puissent aller à
l'école et qu'ils puissent avoir la
conscience sur en regardant vers
l'avenir et je suis mesdames messieurs
je suis sûr que vous avez couvert cet
événement précisément dans cette optique
je vous remercie pour votre attention
bonne soirée à tous 18h43 une conférence
de presse qui aura donc duré
pratiquement une heure puisque vladimir
poutine a
venu au pupitre à 17h48 exactement à
genève les négociations se sont bien
passées ce sont les mots de vladimir
poutine le président russe qui vient
donc de s'exprimer en conférence de
presse après quatre heures d'entretiens
à genève avec son homologue américain
joe biden à moscou et washington sont en
deux pour un retour des ambassadeurs et
conviennent d'une consultation sur la
cybersécurité et adopte une déclaration
commune sur la stabilité stratégique
alors qu'on attend également la
conférence de presse de joe biden elle
est prévue à 19h30 tout à l'heure on
voit des images de la conférence de
presse de joe biden avec le pupitre qui
est installé également
ça ne devrait pas tarder à commencer
18h45 bientôt excellent début de soirée
sur rt france on continue cette édition
spéciale consacrée à cette rencontre au
sommet entre vladimir poutine et joe
byden on file tout de suite du côté de
genève pour retrouver olivier de kerran
flec
olivier la conférence de presse de
vladimir poutine vient donc de se
terminer a débuté à 17h48 il est 18h44
donc pratiquement une heure de
conférence de presse quelles sont les
grandes lignes
à retenir alors effectivement ici à
genève
on a suivi de très près les déclarations
du président russe une conférence de
presse dans sa mais ce qu'on peut
retenir déjà sur l'état d'esprit c'est
que vladimir poutine est bien à qui a
qualifié cette réunion d'une réunion
dans une ambiance sans hostilité certes
des divergences mais pas d'hostilité et
puis il y a eu tout d'abord et bien des
effets concrets de cette réunion pour
commencer et les deux hommes se sont mis
d'accord pour lancer un dialogue
bilatéral globale sur la stabilité
stratégique pour jeter les bases des
futures mesures de contrôle des
armements et d'atténuation des risques
ils ont réaffirmé leur attachement au
principe selon lequel il ne peut y avoir
deux gagnants dans une guerre nucléaire
et puis également une mesure très
concrète qui qui a été prise lors de ce
sommet eh bien c'est la réintégration
des ambassadeurs à la fois russe aux
états unis et de l'ambassadeur américain
à moscou et ce le plus rapidement
possible dès demain visiblement l'écouta
le président poutine
concernant le retour des ambassadeurs à
leur place habituelle de travail à
moscou et washington
nous sommes convenus que cette question
est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
l'horreur abbas a de respectifs demain
ou après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain ou entamer des
consultations sur l'ensemble de notre
interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes j'ai l'impression que les deux
parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions
et puis parmi les sujets qu'on attendait
ce soir c'était le dossier sur l'ukraine
alors pour vladimir poutine et bien les
accords de mines ce que devrait être au
coeur du règlement en ukraine il a
réaffirmé ce soir et il a également dit
que joe biden était d'accord avec cette
proposition le sujet de l'éventuelle
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan a
également a été a également abordé 1
lors de la rencontre mais vite fait pour
reprendre les mots de vladimir poutine
je vous propose de l'écouter justement
sur le dossier ukrainien
concernant nos engagements vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine
nous avons un seul engagement contribuer
à la réalisation des accords de mise
comme si que la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire on va entamer cette
voie sans aucun doute je porte votre
attention sur le fait que novembre
dernier la délégation ukrainienne nous a
adressé ses estimations sur sa leur
vision des accords de minsk
il parle de l'intégration politique du
temps basse dans le système politique
ukrainien et dans la constitution
ukrainienne a donc il faut apporter des
amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne
et deuxième chose c'est que les
frontières entre la russie et l'ukraine
qui passe par le donne basse vont être
occupés par les gardes frontières
ukrainiens lendemain des élections
ukrainiennes qu'est-ce que l'ukraine
propose donc le premier pas c'est de
faire rentrer les tropiques ryan
vers leur base habituelle c'est-à-dire
entrer dans le donbass ensuite fermer
les frontières et troisième chose tenir
les élections
trois mois après ces deux démarches et
rompent on n'a pas besoin d'être juriste
pour comprendre que c'est contraire aux
accords de minsk
alors avant ce sommet un joe biden
s'était affichée en quelque sorte comme
le porte parole des droits de l'homme
avant cette rencontre avec vladimir
poutine alors effectivement les deux
hommes ont abordé cette question des
droits de l'homme et je vous propose
d'écouter la réponse de vladimir poutine
en ce qui concerne les droits nous
continuons à travailler il ya des choses
qui ne respectent ni les lois
américaines ni les principes des droits
de l'homme
il ya guantanamo il ya les liait les
prisons de la cia ou les tortures ont
été appliquées et ça c'est quoi ces les
droits de l'homme peut être je pense que
non est ce que quelqu'un ici dans la
salle sera est prêt à dire que c'est la
défense des droits de l'homme ces
prisons donc c'est la politique réelle
alors voilà beaucoup d'autres sujets ont
également été évoquées ce soir la sphère
navalni le président russe en a dit un
mot il a rappelé que l'homme est bien
avait violé la loi de son pays c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il était
effectivement emprisonnés le président
vladimir poutine qui s'est aussi
exprimée à propos de notre chaîne
rt en disant eh bien que c'était très
difficile pour nous de faire notre à
d'autres travaillent aux états unis que
les règles n'étaient pas celles pour en
vigueur pour les autres chaînes enfin
les dirigeants de la fédération de
russie et des états unis
ils se sont réunis pour faire du monde
un foyer sur pour tous les habitants de
la planète c'est ce qu'a déclaré
vladimir poutine à la fin de sa
conférence de presse et puis il a ajouté
qu aux etats unis lit à la fois des
opposants et des partisans du
développement des relations avec la
fédération de russie
il est difficile de dire quelle force
prévaudront voilà les grandes lignes
qu'on peut retenir ce soir après cette
conférence de presse du président russe
on y reviendra bien dans de bien sûr en
détail un tout au long de la soirée
grégory merci olivier de qui rend flec
pour toutes ces analyses très précises
pour débriefer cette conférence de
presse de vladimir poutine merci
également à jordy demory qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra du côté
de genève sur le toit de l'hôtel
métropole au au bord du lac léman
pour débriefer pour continuer d'analyser
cette prise de parole de vladimir
poutine pratiquement une heure de
conférence de presse pierre guerlain en
direct professeur émérite de
civilisation américaine à l'université
paris ouest nanterre et spécialiste des
états unis pierre guerlain bonsoir merci
de répondre à nos questions sur arte
france juste avant de voir votre image
on a vu également des images
du pupitre de joe biden qui devrait
s'exprimer d'ici quelques instants avec
deux conférences de presse séparées
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé en
juillet 2018 quand donald trump avait
rencontré vladimir poutine elle signe
qui en finlande en finlande
on a vu plusieurs plusieurs points
abordés par olivier de kerentrech sur la
conférence de presse de vladimir poutine
et notamment des points quand même
positif à savoir les ambassadeurs qui
vont réintégrer leur ambassade
américain à moscou et les russes à
washington avec également un travail sur
la cyber sécurité ou encore le fait
washington le site n'a pas à s'inquiéter
d'une militarisation russe de l'article
il ya quand même des points positifs à
retenir qu'elle analyse vous est-ce que
vous tirez de sept heures de conférence
de presse de vladimir poutine alors déjà
ce qui est positif c'est que eu lieu un
sommet parce qu'effectivement tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que les
relations entre les états unis la russie
et est tombé au plus bas au moment on
supposait que toi peut-être aux proches
de la russie mais ce qui est ironique
c'est précisément lors de sa présidence
que c'est tombé au plus bas et il semble
donc y ait une ouverture des deux côtés
mais il faut quand même s'interroger
pour savoir si les forces qui compte
dans les pays en question c'est à dire
les états unis comme la russie vont
donner suite tout ce qui a été annoncé
lorsque par par poutine mais ce qui va
être annoncé aussi par bayonne on sait
qu'aux états unis il ya des forces très
importante
ils sont contre la reprise du dialogue
il ya peut-être des forces en russie qui
sont qui ne sont pas d'accord avec cette
ouverture
néanmoins il faut sur le long terme si
on analyse l'histoire des relations il
ya des moments de très grande tension
dans la guerre froide
il ya des moments de détente et on a vu
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de poutine
en 2000
enfin 99 de 2000 des moments de très
grande proximité lorsque bush a reçu
coûter dans un oranje et des moments de
très grande tension
organisée autour de certains de certains
problèmes
il semblerait qu'il y ait peut-être une
possibilité d'ouverture restez avec nous
pierre guerlain on repart du côté de
genève
pour aller voir notre deuxième envoyé
spécial qui lui a assisté à la
conférence de presse du président russe
et antoine claireaux antoine quelle
était l'atmosphère pendant sept heures
de discours du président russe ou eh
bien on le sait le cet exercice de la
conférence de presse est un exercice
qu'affectionne particulièrement vladimir
poutine c'est pour ça que tout cela
s'est passé dans une atmosphère
globalement détendu à peut-être à
l'exception d'un moment un moment où une
journaliste américaine a posé une
question estimant qu'il n'avait pas
répondu à cette question
elle s'est permis de lui dire du
monsieur le président vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma question est donc va dire
poutine s'est exécuté à continuer à
développer sur le sujet demandé par
cette journaliste américaine autrement
vous avez pu le voir au niveau de la
salle les conditions sanitaires étaient
drastiques avec un espacement entre les
chaises de chaque journaliste de même
pour accéder à cette salle c'était
masques et il fallait également se laver
les mains avec un produit un produit en
liquide hydro alcoolique mais pour
résumer un petit peu la teneur générale
des propos tenus par par vladimir
poutine on peut dire qu'on a senti une
véritable volonté d'ouverture au
dialogue envers les états unis
globalement mais aussi envers joe biden
il a d'ailleurs dressé un portrait tout
à fait laudatif à son encontre il a dit
que c'était une personnalité pondéré
expérimenté expérimenté avec lequel il
était possible d'avoir un dialogue
constructif
merci antoine gayraud pour cette analyse
en direct donc de la ville à la grange
sur les bords du lac léman à genève où
s'est tenu cet entretien ce face à face
entre joe biden et vladimir poutine 80
des changes entre les deux hommes avec
leurs délégations puisque il y avait
également la présence de sergueï lavrov
le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe et le secrétaire d'état américain
anthony blinken
pierre guerlain
vous avez évoqué un des points des
points de convergence ou en tous les cas
le côté positif de cette conférence de
presse on aperçoit ici des images du
pupitre qui attend joe biden pour la
conférence de presse du président
américain c'est dans le centre de presse
des journalistes américains sur les
bords du lac léman à genève
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous à
présent de la prise de parole de joe
biden pierre guerlain y en a vu lors de
l'intervention de poutine dans la
conférence de presse que même s'il y
avait une volonté d'ouverture les points
d'achoppement restent les mêmes sur les
droits humains
il a botté en touche et on peut
s'attendre à ce que byron insistent pour
dire j'ai évoqué ce phénomène et qu' ils
reviennent un discours qui sera
probablement plus dur que ce qui s'est
dit lorsqu'ils étaient face à face parce
que il aa
il doit faire attention à la réception
de ce sommet de ce discours aux états
unis donc je pense qu'il va insister sur
les points de désaccord qui restent mais
aussi sur les possibilités d'accord sur
la limitation des armements nucléaires
par exemple on parle de l'armement il ya
beaucoup de points qualité qui ont été
évoquées notamment la cyber sécurité qui
était au coeur à l'agenda de cette de
cette rencontre deux présidents ont
convenu d'ailleurs de travailler main
dans la main et d'organiser des
consultations dans
l'intérêt des deux pays oui tout à fait
la seule chose c'est que l'esl
espionnage ne va jamais s'arrêter
c'est à dire que l'année sable du côté
américain et les agences russes ont
continué à centrer ce pionner on peut
espérer qu'il n'y aura pas de tentative
de déstabilisation de certaines
entreprises que ce sera un peu plus
contrôlés notamment contrôler des
criminels qui opèrent sur le territoire
de telle dalle pays justement pierre
guerlain je vous propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine à ce sujet de la
cybercriminalité concernant la
cybersécurité non nous sommes convenus
du fait que nous allons commencer des
consultations à mon avis c'est très
important
concernant la responsabilité à assumer
je vous informe ce sont les choses qui
sont évidentes est connu pour le grand
public les sources américaines
je crains de confondre peut-être leur
appellation et leur nom donc les sources
et américaines estiment que la grande le
grand nombre la majeure partie des cyber
attaques viennent du territoire
américain
deuxième place revient au canada ensuite
deux pays de l'amérique latine et la
grande bretagne concernant le territoire
russe qui est l'origine des
cyberattaques ne figure pas dans cette
liste
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose en cours
2020 nous avons reçu des demandes de la
part de la partie américaine qui
concernait les cyber attaques comme quoi
les sites américains ont été attaqués
depuis le territoire russe et de
demandes cette année si nous avons donné
des réponses adressées à des collègues
américains
deux seins par la partie russe a dépêché
cinq demandes et cette année 6,35
demande mais pour le moment nous n'avons
aucune réponse
il y a donc du pain sur la planche et la
question devrait assumer cette
responsabilité c'est la question des
négociations on va entamer ses
consultations et nos estimant que ce
secteur de cyber sécurité est très
important partout dans le monde pour les
états unis en particulier et pour la
fédération de russie également par
exemple nos savons qu'il ya eu des cyber
attaques dirigées contre une société
gazière aux états unis et qui a dû payer
à des personnes qui ont fait chanter
cette entreprise 5 millions de dollars
une partie de cette somme a été
remboursée mais la russie n'y est pour
rien nous sommes confrontés également à
ces menaces par exemple le système de
santé public d'une région du hand
régions russes a été cible de ces
attaques
et ce travail et est coordonné depuis le
territoire américain
je ne pense pas que les autorités
américaines
en quelques intérêts dans ces attaques
il faut donc abandonné toutes sortes d'
intox
au niveau d'experts nous avons besoin de
travailler dans les intérêts des états
unis et de la fédération de russie qui
est nos sommes convenus et nous y sommes
prêts voilà donc au sujet de la
cybercriminalité vladimir poutine qui
explique moscou et washington vont
travailler
il ya d'ailleurs une une déclaration
commune des deux présidents à son sujet
on l'aura un petit peu plus tard pierre
pierre guerlain on sait que la
cybercriminalité c'est l'une des lignes
rouges
on en a beaucoup parlé pendant pendant
ce sommet mais vladimir poutine a
également évoqué je cite cette phrase
nous ne sommes pas allés dans le détail
en ce qui concerne les lignes rouges
donc du coup ils vont continuer à
travailler ensemble à dessus sur sur ce
dossier la cybercriminalité
qu'est ce qu'il faut en attendre
concrètement selon vous dans les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois en matière
d'espionnage
on le dit la vérité que l'otan après et
les siona je continue toujours
on sait pas à suite aux révélations de
snowdon en 2013 comme dans les états
unis espionné tout le monde après il ya
eu de l'histoire du danemark qui
transférait informations sur les leaders
allemands et français aux états unis
tout ça ça va continuer par contre il ya
peut-être un domaine où il est possible
d'avoir une coopération internationale
qui implique états unis et russie
c'est effectivement la criminalité
lorsque des individus qui ne sont pas
des agents des états attaques des
institutions et là on peut penser que
tous les états du monde ont un intérêt à
contrôler les activités criminelles que
quelle que soit l'origine de
le départ de ces attaques criminelles
mais en ce qui concerne l'espionnage
évidemment c'était sq date va continuer
pierre guerlain
d'une manière générale comment est-ce
que vous analysez
cette cette journée jusqu'à présent même
si on le rappelle joe biden n'a toujours
par parler normalement c'est à 19h30 qui
doit s'exprimer mais on voit tout est en
place du côté du lac léman et du centre
de presse des journalistes américains de
genève
s'il ya un bilan avant même que joe
biden ne parle lequel serait-il alors le
bilan qui est comme vous l'avez dit déjà
positif c'est les gens se parlent
il ya retour de diplomatie ce qui fait
baisser les tensions avec les risques
d'accident nucléaire
ça c'est tout à fait positif ensuite
pour faire le bilan en véritable de ses
rôles à 2,7 de ce sommet il faudra
attendre les réactions des systèmes
politiques surtout américains mais aussi
en russie pour voir comment c'est perçu
eux
obama avait fait avait lancé un bruit
cette 1 re démarrage relations avec la
russie
en 2011 on sait que les choses ont
dégénéré par la suite
donc il faut être très prudent il est
possible que bayonne quand même faisait
partie de l'équipe obama soit moi
aiguillonnés par le complexe militaro
américain militaires américains pour
être dur avec la russie mais les choses
ne peuvent pas évoluer très rapidement
et là on a peut-être le début de quelque
chose après tout va dépendre de comment
les choses évoluent dans le système
politique américain pour savoir si s'est
concrétisé par quelque chose le fait que
baye d'aidé décidé par exemple de signer
l'accord stats c'est déjà une différence
avec un mistral sottom qui est en soi
positive merci pierre guerlain pour
avoir réagi et répondu à nos questions
directes sur sur rt france
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
émérite de civilisation américaine et
spécialiste des etats-unis une heure de
conférence de presse presque pour
vladimir poutine après 4h des changes à
la ville à la grange du côté de
genève une rencontre au sommet et que le
blanchemaison qui vient de nous
rejoindre bonsoir claude vous êtes
expert international en relations
internationales
comment est-ce que vous
analyser cette journée qui n'est pas
encore terminée puisqu'on le voit sur
ces images sont gros écran en face de
nous il va y avoir la conférence de
presse de joe biden dialogue constructif
manifestement entre deux personnalités
très expérimenté en matière de relations
internationales et qui ont décidé de ne
pas s'envoyer des anathèmes à la figure
mais de traiter de façon concrète les
sujets et de prendre des décisions assez
souvent de procédure puisque il a été
décidé de créer plusieurs comités à très
haut niveau pour engager les travaux sur
la stabilité stratégique sur la
limitation des armements mais aussi sur
la cybercriminalité
ce qui est une avancée me semble-t-il
assez considérable autre avancée
il s'agit notamment du retour des
ambassadeurs je vous propose d'ailleurs
d'écouter vladimir poutine à ce sujet il
s'est exprimé et normalement ça devrait
avoir lieu très prochainement écouter le
président russe
concernant le retour des ambassadeurs à
leur place habituelle de travail à
moscou et à washington
nous nous sommes convenus que cette
question est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
l'horreur abbas a de respectifs demain
ou après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministère russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain ou entamer des
consultations sur l'ensemble de notre
interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes j'ai l'impression que les deux
parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions telles blanchemaison viens
d'entendre vladimir poutine au sujet de
route du retour des ambassadeurs c
ça va dans le bon sens les deux
ambassadeurs étaient présents d'ailleurs
à genève évidemment en tant qu ancien
ambassadeur
je ne trouve pas que c'est une très
bonne idée de retirer les ambassadeurs
surtout quand ça va mal parce qu'ils
sont là pour porter les messages les
bons mais aussi les mauvais et ils sont
là surtout pour négocier donc c'est en
effet une très bonne nouvelle qu'on
retrouve la normalité des choses et que
les deux ambassades puisse fonctionner
avec leur chef de poste titulaire ça
c'est un dossier qui fait sourire en
tout les gars
ça va dans le bon sens on a évoqué la
cybercriminalité avec la volonté de
travailler un point de discorde c'est
l'ukraine qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
sur le dossier ukrainien pour le moment
moi je suis entendu que la conférence de
presse de du président russe on va voir
ce que dit le pré vert américain
président russe a été très clair c'est
la position classique
c'est d'ailleurs aussi la position
française et allemande
il faut appliquer les accords de minsk
il faut les appliquer tout misé rien que
minsk alors évidemment il ya une
divergence d'appréciation entre moscou
et kiev sur l'interprétation de la
manière dont doivent se dérouler
l'élection à donetsk et à louhansk la
partie russe considère conformément à la
lettre d'ailleurs des accords de minsk
qu' il faut d'abord modifier la
constitution pour donner l'autonomie à
ces deux provinces qu'il faut qu'ils les
négociations entre kiev et les autorités
de fait de ces deux provinces pour
définir les conditions dans lesquelles
se dérouleront l'élection et kiev a
tendance à dire il faut d'abord que
j'envoie mes gardes frontières sur la
frontière que donc les services publics
de kiev reprennent pied dans ces deux
provinces
et puis après on aura les élections
trois mois plus tard alors effectivement
il faut respecter les accords de misc
mais peut-être y at-il aussi matière à
négocier pour savoir qui contrôlait
effectivement la frontière dans la
période intérimaire jusqu'à l'élection
ça pourrait aussi être l'ouest toujours
au sujet de l'ukraine on sait qu'il ya
eu
le g7 auquel a participé joe biden très
récemment le week-end dernier en
angleterre ensuite il ya eu le sommet
sur l'otan à bruxelles lundi et cette
occasion il ya une sortie de volodymyr
zen style le président ukrainien qui a
dit regretter le fait que joe biden
rencontre en premier vous l'a dit mir
poutine qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
veut dire derrière je crois que les
berlines ce qui a joué son rôle
notamment par rapport à ses électeurs à
kiev si vous voulez mais il est il est
invité dans quelques semaines à
washington et je crois qu'il aura donc
sur d'autres compensations puisqu'il
sera reçu par joe biden à washington je
crois aussi que pendant les discussions
d'aujourd'hui l'admirent poutine a tracé
l'une des lignes rouges sur ce sujet
évidemment comme on le sait il n'est pas
acceptable pour la russie qu'on envisage
que l'ukraine devient je devienne un
jour membre de l'otan et ça c'est
vraiment une ligne rouge pour moscou
autre ligne rouge les droits de l'homme
on l'a entendu également la sphère
alexeï navalni avec
vladimir poutine qui a dit que alexeï
navalni savaient qu'ils violaient la loi
par rapport à ça qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir également
on en reste enfin en effet à la thèse
officielle du kremlin qui est que
monsieur lavallée a été condamnés par
des tribunaux pour des litiges
commerciaux que il a été mis en liberté
provisoire et qu' il n'a pas respecté
les termes de cette liberté vi n'a pas
été pointés au commissariat ou au
ministère de la justice pour la bonne
raison qu'il était non pas réfugié mais
qu'il était soigné à ce moment là en
allemagne parce qu'entre temps il avait
été empoisonné
voilà donc ceci évidemment chacun
connaît l'histoire qu'on l'on peut
raconter de façon différente mais il est
clair que monsieur navalni restera sans
doute en prison pour un certain temps et
qu'il continuera à poursuivre son
parcours judiciaire
monsieur poutine a aussi contre-attaqué
et ce qui est intéressant en parlant de
l'application des droits de l'homme aux
états unis en citant les violences aux
états unis des des particuliers qui
pouvaient se faire tuer sans raison
parce que la sécurité n'est pas assurée
dans certaines villes donc il a contre
attaqué d'une certaine manière c'est
très bon signe parce que ça veut dire
qu'ils acceptent de discuter des droits
de l'homme il ya un point qui a
également été évoqué ce sont les
journalistes notamment ceux de
rt de spoutnik aux états unis je vous
propose d'ailleurs d'écouter la réaction
de vladimir poutine n'a pas encore la
réaction de vladimir poutine mais qui a
réagi aux accréditations non reçus par
les médias rochette ou des écoutes nique
comment va réagir selon vous joe biden
d'ailleurs on attend toujours le
président américain tout est prêt sur
les bords du lac léman
on le voit sur sur ces images de bon
nous on est un petit peu tôt pour le
dire parce que comme vous le savez sur
beaucoup de sujets en matière de
politique étrangère et aurait été de
pouvoir il ya le président des états
unis
et puis à le congrès donc la question
est de savoir ce que monsieur turpin
yens vouloir négocier avec le congrès
sur ce sujet je me permets de vous
couper parce qu'on a récupéré le son de
vladimir poutine à ce sujet écouter le
président de la fédération de russie
licha relation to day et s'écoute nick
qui ont été privé d'accréditation et
c'était la meilleure rotation de la part
de la russie tandis que roche auto day
rempli de toutes les exigences des
autorités américaines sur le territoire
américain
quoique il ya toutes sortes d'obstacles
de nature financière par exemple nous
n'avons pas cette sorte de problèmes et
les médias américaines ne respecte
pleinement les exigences étaient sept au
virus quand même mais j'espère qu'on va
réussir grâce à notre ministère des
affaires étrangères de le faire 19h15 on
a cru un moment que joe biden était en
train d'arriver certains journalistes se
sont se sont levés et finalement ils se
sont vite rassis en tous les cas dès que
joe biden prendra la parole évidemment
on filera du côté de genève
que blanchemaison par rapport donc à
cette question de l'accréditation des
journalistes et
du côté de washington comment est-ce que
vous réagissez je pense qu'il y aura un
débat effectivement et que et que le
congrès va vouloir probablement mettre
son grain de sel dans cette affaire donc
ça sera une question de négociations
entre la maison blanche et le congrès et
encore une fois il est un petit peu
difficile de connaître le résultat je
pense que finalement au bout du compte
rt rassure l'accréditation mais je ne
sais pas à quel terme exactement
un mot également c'est très important
c'était à l'agenda évidemment
aujourd'hui sur la stabilité stratégique
il y a eu le traité ciel ouvert
définitivement clos d'ailleurs sa date
de pas très longtemps puisque les les
députés russes ont décidé de sortir de
ce traité ça a été a été ratifiée mais
c'était après que les états unis en soit
sorti
et aussi le traité est finie les forces
de
nucléaire de portée intermédiaire ça
c'est fini après après que les états
unis sous donald trump soit sorti il
reste quand même le traité new start qui
a été prolongé en début d'année par par
joe biden et
selon vladimir poutine eh bien il s'est
félicité d'ailleurs de 7,2 que ce
contrat soit soit prolongée
et bien selon le président russe moscou
et washington vont travailler sur sur la
stabilité et le désarmement
ça c'est une bonne chose il ya donc il
était un des résultats très positifs en
effet de la réunion d'aujourd'hui
puisque les deux présidents arrêtés sont
d'accord pour considérer que les deux
pays ont une réalisons une
responsabilité énorme vis-à-vis du monde
puisque ce sont les deux pays qui
possèdent le plus de gvt nucléaire le
plus de missiles pour délivrer ses âgées
et plus claire et qui sont aux
avant-postes de des progrès
technologiques en matière d'armement par
conséquent ils ont une responsabilité
évidente et que donc ils ont décidé
aujourd'hui de mettre en place des
groupes de travail nécessaire pour
avancer dans cette voie
en effet monsieur byden avait donné un
bon signal en décidant de proroger pour
cinq ans
le traité new start maintenant il ya
beaucoup de travail parce que les autres
traités qui ont été dénoncées auparavant
ne sont peut être plus exactement adapté
à réalité stratégique aujourd'hui on a
aussi entendu les deux présidents dire
séparément qu'il fallait une stabilité
stratégique qu'il fallait une
prévisibilité dans le domaine
stratégique
les deux ont employé les mêmes mots dans
des interviews qui précédait cette
journée d'aujourd'hui
juste pour revenir sur ce que vous avez
dit concernant la sphère navalni il
n'avait pas respecté les conditions
judiciaires de pendant qu'il était seul
en allemagne c'est pas pendant qu'ils
étaient en allemagne c'était avant
pendant qu'il était pendant qu'il était
en russie l'avait
violé au moins six fois dans les mots
qu'il avait qui avaient précédé toute
cette affaire pour remettre les choses
les choses au clair
donc beaucoup de sujets qui ont été
évoqués au cours de cette conférence de
presse de vladimir poutine un mot
peut-être également sur ce qui s'est
passé avant la conférence de presse sur
cette journée au global qui a commencé
très tôt avec l'arrivée de vladimir
poutine à 12h27 exactement quand son
avion a atterri à l'aéroport
international de genève mais ensuite
j'ai vu tout le protocole et notamment
cette poignée de main on la minute et
elle a duré 4 4 secondes
dans les gestes dans la gestuelle dans
les prises de parole on a vu
vladimir poutine
répondre à joe biden puisque joe biden a
dit c'est quand même mieux de se voir en
tête à tête il l'a dit en premier puis
ensuite vladimir poutine a dit qu'il
espérait une rencontre productive dans
tout cet aspect qui a entouré cette
cette journée qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous retenez gérer du rsa sous la
forme suivante si vous voulez bien
une rencontre entre deux professionnels
et à dire qu' il y avait probablement
assez peu d'affect dans les gestes qui
ont été faits mais il y avait un très
grand professionnalisme donc il est tout
à fait normal que les deux chefs d'état
mais paraître vous coupez joe biden est
en train d'arriver au pupitre du côté de
genève on va écouter la conférence de
presse du président américain s'est
adressé une longue journée
ah non vous ici bien dd je sais que remy
c'était pas trop difficile de franchir
ses portes n'est ce pas bien quoi qu'il
en soit bonsoir tout le monde
eh bien je viens de conclure la dernière
réunion de ce long voyage de cette
semaine avec le sommet ue etats unis
russie mais je sais qu'il ya eu beaucoup
de discussions autour de cette rencontre
mais en fait c'est rencontre était tout
à fait direct pour ce qui me concerne
premièrement il n'y a rien qui puisse
remplacer le dialogue en tête à tête
entre dirigeants cela est impossible
le président poutine et moi même
partageons une responsable des
techniques à savoir gérer la relation
entre deux pays très puissant
cette relation qui doit être stable qui
doit être prévisible et cette relation
doit nous permettre de coopérer lorsque
cela relève de nos intérêts mutuels et
là où il ya des différences je le veux
que le président poutine comprennent
pourquoi je dis ce que je dis et moi
quoi je fais ce que je fais
et comment nous allons réagir rapport à
des actions spécifiques qui sont nocives
pour les intérêts américains bien je dis
au président poutine que mon agenda
n'est pas contre la russie ou contre qui
que ce soit d'autre
mon agenda et pour le peuple américain
pour lutter contre la queue vide
renconstruire notre économie pour
rétablir nos relations au tour du monde
avec nos amis et alliés et protéger le
peuple américain
cela constitue ma responsabilité en tant
que président je lui ai également dit
qu'aucun président des états unis ne
peut être honnête envers le peuple
américain s'il ne parle pas aux efforts
pour défendre nos valeurs démocratiques
se porter garant pour les valeurs
universelles de la liberté dont sont
dotés les hommes et les femmes selon
nous cela relève de l'adn de notre pays
donc les droits humains figurant
toujours sur la table je lui ai dit il
ne s'agit pas simplement de s'en prendre
à la russie lorsqu'il viole les droits
de l'homme non cela relève de notre état
le profond comment est-ce que moi
président des états unis
pourrais-je m'abstenir de parler contre
les violations des droits de l'homme je
le lui ai dit
contrairement à d'autres pays comme la
russie nous sommes uniquement le produit
d'une idée je les dis encore et toujours
et je continuerai de le dire nous sommes
le produit d'une idée nos droits ne sont
pas dérivé du gouvernement nous avons
ses droits parce que nous sommes nés
tout simplement et nous laisser dont au
gouvernement
et donc je lui ai dit c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous allons susciter faire
parler de nos préoccupations dans des
affaires telles que celle de monsieur la
vanille j'ai dit clairement à monsieur
poutine que nous allons continuer par
des questions des droits de l'homme car
cela relève de notre identité c'est
qu'ils nous sommes pour nous ce sont des
vérités évidentes à savoir tous les
hommes et les femmes
nous n'avons pas toujours été à la
hauteur de ses des idéaux mais nous
avons maintenu ses engagements
de plus en plus de populations
j'ai parlé de la situation des citoyens
américains qui sont loin d'être witch
est également parlé de questions de
radio free europe radio rock qui puisse
fonctionner et l'importance d'une presse
libre de la liberté d'expression je dis
clairement que nous ne tolérons pas les
attaques contre le souverain et
démocratique où les tentatives de lutter
contre les élections démocratiques
nous allons réagir essentiellement jeudi
auprès des routines kindle vont doter de
règles de la situation de base est que
nous pouvons tous respectés je lui ai
dit également dès qu'il ya des domaines
de coopération d'intérêt mutuel pour nos
populations
le peuple américain est pour le peuple
russe mais également sur le bien du
monde entier pour la sécurité du monde
entier
l'un des ces domaines c'est la stabilité
stratégique
vous me demandez souvent de quoi ai je
parlé avec poutine avant de venir je lui
dis que je n'ai pas négocié avec la
ligue du jeu lui dit ce que j'avais
l'intention de faire depuis le début à
savoir parler de ces questions de la
stabilité stratégique et pour essayer de
se doter d'un mécanisme gérer ces
dossiers nous avons parlé en détail des
décès date que devront prendre en
matière de contrôle des armements
les étapes nécessaires pour réduire les
risques de conflits inutiles à
prévisible et aujourd'hui nous allons
lancer un dialogue stratégique de
stabilité c'est un langage diplomatique
pour dire que nos experts militaires le
des pneumatiques se rencontrant pour
créer un mécanisme qui pourra déboucher
sur le contrôle des nouveaux armements
sophistiqués et dangereux qui sont déjà
en train
naître qui réduisent les délais de
réponse qui rit augmente les risques de
guerre accidentelle nous avons parlé de
manière détaillée de ces systèmes
d'armement nous avons également passé
beaucoup de temps à parler de la
cybersécurité j'ai parlé de cette idée
que certains a fracturé stratégique ne
doivent jamais être attaqué point à la
ligne
de manière cyberéthique aux autres je
lui donnais une liste si je m'abuse je
n'ai pas de mois en mois mais il ya 16
entités spécifiques 16 entités définit
comme relevant de l'infrastructure ce
fondamental des états unis les six
thèmes de l'eau ce principe est
fondamentale et cela doit être étayé par
la pratique les pays responsables à
prendre des mesures contre les criminels
qui prennent des mesures de rançons sur
leur propre territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus de
missionner des experts des deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compréhension de
ce qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui toutes origines dans la
ou l'autre de nos pays il y à une longue
liste de dossiers sur lesquels nous
avons discuté il ya un besoin urgent de
rouvrir les couloirs en méditerranée en
série pour que l'on puisse apporter de
la nourriture les éléments fondamentaux
pour les gens qui sont affamés comment
on reconstruire et comment cela relève
des états des intérêts des états unis et
de la russie pour y est ce que l'iran ne
se dote pas d'armes nucléaires
nous avons décidé de travailler ensemble
cela relève des intérêts doit aussi
comme des nôtres comment pouvons-nous vs
que l'article de même une zone de
coopération plutôt qu'une zone de
conflit j'écoutais des séquences la
conférence de presse du président
poutine et il a parlé du fait que nous
devons avoir un modus operandi pour nous
permettre de faire en sorte que
l'article soit effectivement une zone
libre
et comment pouvons nous tous ensemble
contribuer à cette lutte contre cette
résurgence du terrorisme en afghanistan
cela relève encore une fois des intérêts
de la russie d'éviter un retour du
terrorisme en afghanistan il ya
également des dossiers plus difficile
j'ai dit que les états unis maintenaient
leur engagement indéfectible vis-à-vis
de l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
nous avons décidé de suivre la voie
diplomatique par rapport à l'apport de
minsk j'ai parlé de mes préoccupations
relevant de l'âme et de russie il
n'était pas en désaccord par rapport à
ce qui s'était passé il avait tout
simplement pas de vue différents je sais
que vous avez beaucoup de questions je
vais conclure avec ce propos il était
important de se rencontrer en personne
pour qu'il n'y ait aucune erreur aucune
fausse représentation en ce qui concerne
ce que je souhaitais communiqué j'ai
fait ce que je voulais faire
premièrement j'ai identifié des domaines
de travail pratique pour le du pays pour
favoriser nos intérêts mutuels pour nous
mêmes et pour le monde
deuxièmement communiquer de manière
directe directement que les états unis
réagiront à des actions qui sont contre
nos intérêts vitaux au sud aux alliés et
troisièmement énoncer clairement quelles
sont nos priorités quels sont nos
valeurs pour cool ils entendent
directement de ma bouche et je dois vous
dire que le la tonalité de ses
rencontres de plus de quatre heures
l'ambiance était bonne positive il n'y
avait pas d'action fort ou de prise de
parole il y avait des moments où nous
étions d'accord il a discuté son point
de vue expliqué les moyens mais cela a
été fait sans aucune hyperbole ça on
voit beaucoup trop de ces choses
actuellement au cours de la semaine
écoulée je crois j'espère que les états
unis ont démontré au monde que nous
sommes de retour
nous sommes aux côtés de nos alliés nous
avons radier des démocraties prendre des
engagements concertée nous attaquer aux
plus grands défis du monde actuel est
présentement nous
avons établi des bases claires pour nous
permettre de travailler avec la russie
et de gérer la relation entre nos deux
pays
il y a encore beaucoup de travail devant
nous non je ne dis pas que tout est
accompli mais nous avons fait beaucoup
de choses pendant ce voyage
et avant de répondre à vos questions je
dirais une toute dernière chose écoutons
écouter il s'agit de l'étape suivante
géant encore une fois j'ai écouté une
grande partie de la conférence de presse
du président poutine
et comme il l'a dit lui-même il s'agit
d'une des décisions pratiques dit que
nous devons prendre ou ne pas prendre
c'est d'ici un an aux six mois nous
verrons effectivement si nous pourrons
avoir ce dialogue stratégique nous nous
rendrons compte si nous pourrons parler
de ces choses de la libération des
personnes qui sont en prise en russie
nous l'apprendrons si nous aurons là un
accord de sécurité qui commence à
rétablir un semblant d'ordre
parce que les pays qui sont les plus
susceptibles d'être lésées ce sont les
grands pays
par exemple lorsque je parle de
l'oléoduc qui a été pris par an 100 pour
5 millions de dollars aux états unis
j'aurais parlé comment le sentez-vous si
on demandait en rançons vous au lieu du
que ça contraire cela relève pas que
deux intérêts propres cela relève de nos
intérêts mutuels
je répondrai à vos questions comme
d'habitude on m'a communiqué une liste
de personnes que je doit interpeller
johnattan de la société de presse
merci monsieur le président les
renseignements américains disent que la
russie a essayé de s'ingérer dans les
duels sélection américaine que les
russes sont
derrière les attaques de sur le winch le
président poutine vient de dire qu'il
n'acceptait aucune responsabilité pour
ces choses votre peau les soeurs n'a pas
demandé à ce que poutine arrête ces
perturbations donc avez vous réalisé sur
le plan concret aujourd'hui pour éviter
que cela ne se reproduise à l'avenir
bien j empêcher que cela se reproduise g
qu'il sait que je ferais prendrait des
mesures comme c'était la toute dernière
fois en l'occurrence qui s'est passé
nous avons clairement dit que nous ne
permettrons pas bateau rions pas que
celui-ci se poursuivent et par
conséquent il y a eu des rappels les
ambassadeurs nous avons fermé des
installations aux états unis il sait
qu'il ya des conséquences est bien l'une
des conséquences est que je sais je ne
sais pas si je cesse je soupçonne que
vous pensez que cela ne compte pas cela
compte pour lui pour les dirigeants des
grands pays
ce qui compte c'est sa crédibilité à
l'échelle mondiale sa crédibilité à
l'échelle mondiale s'amenuisent
comment les a dit mr est il perçu par le
reste du monde
si nous nous nous ingérions directement
dans les élections d'autres pays et si
tout le monde savait qu'est ce que ce
serait si nous pratiquions ses activités
qu'ils pratiquent lui-même
cela réduit le prestige d'un pays qui
essaye de maintenir son rang en tant que
grande puissance mondiale
donc cela dit ce n'est pas ce que je
fais qui compte seulement ce sont les
mesures prises par d'autres pays la
russie en l'occurrence qui sont
contraires aux normes internationales et
c'est le prix à payer
ils ne sont pas en mesure de dicter ce
qui se passe dans le reste du monde
il ya d'autres pays importants notamment
des états unis
parmi eux monsieur le président
s'agissant de conscience vous venez de
dire que vous nous avez beaucoup parlé
de droits de l'homme que se passerait-il
si le dirigeant de l'opposition alexis
navalni nous
rae je lui dis clairement que je crois
que les conséquences de cela serait
dévastatrice pour la russie je reviens
mon point initial que se passerait-il si
il dit il ne s'agit pas de nuire à naval
ni bruit ni toutes ces choses pour
rationaliser le traitement de navalni et
ensuite il meurt en prison
je lui dis que cela compte énormément
quand un pays en fait bon on m'a demandé
pourquoi cela était importante des
problèmes avec le président va syrie
parce que il viole les normes
internationales avec le traité et des
armes sur les armes chimiques il n'est
pas fiable
c'est une question de confiance c'est
une question de sa capacité d'influer
les autres pays de manière positive
écoutez voudriez vous échanger notre
économie pour l'économie russe est en
fait nous avons parlé de commerce
je n'ai pas de problème de commercer
avec la russie tant qu'ils respectent
les normes internationales
il relève de nos intérêts que le peuple
russe prenne son essor s'épanouit soit
pas économique mais s'ils n'agissent pas
en fonction des normes internationales
et bien que se passe-t-il
cela ne se passera pas non seulement
avec les états unis mais avec d'autres
pays et il nous
il en a parlé il y à ce besoin de tendre
la main à d'autres pays qui investiront
en russie et bien ses pin investiront
pas tant qu'on ne peut pas les
convaincre que il y assez de la scion
par exemple l'homme d'affaires américain
qui est en résidence surveillée et
assigné à résidence
si vous voulez que les investisseurs
américains viennent chez vous libérez le
changer la dynamique parce que les
hommes d'affaires américains sont pas
prêts à aller sur place à moscou je sais
qu'on dit que la politique étrangère
relève de ses compétences
extraordinaires qu'il y ait un code
secret
en fait la politique étrangère c'est une
extension logique des relations
personnelles c'est le fonctionnement de
la nature humaine il faut comprendre
lorsque vous dirige un pays qui ne
respectent pas les normes nationales et
pourtant vous avez besoin de ces normes
internationales qui doivent être prises
en charge pour que vous puissiez en
profiter vous même
et bien cela vous est nuisible ce n'est
pas une bonne réponse mme debbie dunn a
dit non ils ans il va envahir la rue
sinon ce n'est pas vrai c'est une blague
mais mon point fondamental est le
suivant les choses sont plus compliquées
que cela
david singer je croyais avoir vu david
merci monsieur le président en amont de
cette discussion on a beaucoup parlé du
fait que les deux pays allaient entamer
une nouvelle guerre froide et je
voudrais savoir s'il y a à la suite de
ces diffusions et pendant je vais ôter
mon ma veste
il fait chaud y at il des raisons de
penser que monsieur poutine a décidé de
s'écarter de son rôle fondamental de 10
rupteurs de perturbateurs surtout un
descripteur des états unis et de l'otan
et pour rebondir sur cette liste
complète des nids d'infrastructures
critiques aux états unis
avez vous énoncez très clairement quels
seraient les pénalités s'il y avait des
ingérences sur ces avoirs sont dures
critiques
est-ce que c'est resté vague at il
répondu d'une manière d'une autre ou
bien je vais répondre tout d'abord votre
deuxième question je lui dis que nous
avons des capacités cybernétique
importante
il le sait il ne sait pas exactement de
quoi il s'agit mais il le sait et en
fait ils ont violé ces normes
fondamentales et s'ils le font nous
allons réagir sur le plan cybernétique
il le sait de manière cybernétique un
deuxièmement
je crois ce que ce qu'il veut sans doute
éviter à présent c'est une guerre froide
je ne vais pas le citer ce ne serait pas
appropriée mais je vais vous poser une
question rhétorique il a une frontière
de milliers de kilomètres avec la chine
la chine avance rapidement elle veut
être la première économie du monde
elle veut être la force militaire la
plus puissante du monde et vous êtes
dans une situation où votre économie est
en difficulté vous devez avancer de
manière agressive en tout cas pour ce
qui concerne la croissance
et puis je ne pense pas qu'ils
recherchent une guerre froide avec les
états unis
je ne pense pas comme je lui dis je dis
votre génération est la mienne nous
avons dix années de distance nous sommes
pas à kumba yacouba comeau disais aux
années 60 c'est pas le grand amour mais
cela relève pas de nos intérêts dus
votre lumière pour nous trouver dans une
situation nous serions dans une nouvelle
guerre froide et je crois
fondamentalement qu'il le pense aussi qu
il le comprend mais cela ne veut pas
dire qu'il est prêt à renoncer à ses
armes non il est toujours préoccupée
d'être encerclés toujours préoccupé par
l'idée que nous cherchons à le rabaisser
un certain niveau il a toujours ses
préoccupations mais je ne pense pas que
ce sont les forces motrices de la
relation qu'il cherche avec les états
unis
jennifer jean fadjri cops
merci monsieur le président yat-il
réserve toute particulière qui
expliquerait pourquoi ce sommet n'a duré
que trois heures on pensait que ça va
durer 4 5 heures est une raison pour
laquelle le sommet était plus court le
président poutine a dit qu'il n'ya pas
qui veut pas de menaces ou de tactique
de la peur est tous d'accord qu'il n'y
avait pas de menaces ou de tactique de
la peur
et avez vous parlé de l'afghanistan et
du retrait sur de nos troupes
oui oui oui et oui je vais répondre à
votre première partie la raison pour
laquelle le sommet n'a pas duré plus
longtemps ce parce que la dernière fois
deux chefs d'état avaient passé plus de
deux heures en conversation directe
autour de la table en parlant de détails
minutieux
vous connaissez peut-être une époque où
cela s'est passé
pas moi donc il n'était pas nécessaire
lorsque le groupe élargit nous a rejoint
nos collègues des renseignements des
affaires étrangères à savoir donc le
secrétaire d'état était avec moi pour
toute la durée nos ambassadeurs tout le
monde nous aura joindre nous avions déjà
couvert tant de sujets donc nous avons
fait un sommaire lui et moi des sujets
dont nous avons parlé messieurs lavrov
et monsieur blinken en parler des sujets
abordés
nous avons parlé de sujets qui
nécessitent plus d'applications pour
éviter tous les malentendus
par conséquent en fait après ces deux
heures nous nous sommes consultés et
nous avons nous avons dit d'accord et
est maintenant et bien que va-t-il se
passer matin et bien nous allons pouvoir
prendre du recul et regarder de l'avant
li 6 3 6 mois et nous dire eh bien les
choses sur lesquelles nous nous sommes
entendus on est le marché sommes nous
plus proche
pour parler de stabilité stratégique est
ce que nous avançons donc ça sera le
test je ne dis pas que le président et
moi même avons convenu que nous
pourrions tous ici tout cela est que
tous ceux ci fonctionnera non ce n'est
pas ce que je dis je dis tout simplement
qu'il ya des perspectives réelles
d'amélioration des relations entre nos
deux pays
sans renoncer à crois que ce soit sur la
base de nos principes et de nos valeurs
non non il n'y avait pas de menace et en
fait j'ai entendu qu'il avait cité ma
mère et d'autres personnes aujourd'hui
comme on le dit salah vous choquerait
venu dans ma part c'est un peu familier
et nous avons parlé de choses basiques
est fondamentale
vous savez comment je suis j'explique
les choses sur le plan personnel comment
je vois les choses qu'il n'y avait pas
de menace ou tout simplement des
déclarations simples c'est bien nous
ferons ceci nous ferons cela ne lui fais
part de mes positions je lui ai expliqué
ce que nous pourrions accomplir ensemble
et que se passa-t-il co for you know
s'il y avait des violations de la
souveraineté américaine
c'est lui qui nous a posé des questions
sur l'afghanistan il nous a dit qu'il
espérait que nous serions en mesure de
maintenir la paix la sécurité je lui
répondis que cela dépend en grande
partie de vous il a répondu qu'il était
prêt je cite à nous aider je n'entrerai
pas dans les détails il a dit qu'il
serait prêt à nous aider avec l'iran et
je lui ai dit ce que nous souhaitions
faire en matière de stabilité et de
sécurité économiques la sécurité
physique pour le peuple syrien et le
peuple libyen dont nous avons eu ces
discussions
hamish oui merci monsieur le président
vous nous dites que vous n'avez pas fait
de menaces mais ce que vous avez lancer
des ultimatums en ce qui concerne le
logiciel de rancio le skins et s'agit
sort de ces groupes de travail sur la
gérance russe et sur la subir sécurité
et bien ce sera très facile par exemple
s'agissant d'un cyber sécurité nous
allons voir s'il s'attaque aux criminels
nous de logiciels rossant sur le
territoire je ne pense pas qu'ils ont
planifié en l'occurrence vont-ils agir
eh bien nous ne rendrons compte eux
quels sont les engagements que nous
pouvons prendre en matière d'action de
mesures suite à la violation d'une
augmentation par la russie cavour nous
accepter de faire en fait nous avons une
véritable chance d'avancer et je pense
que l'une des choses que nous avons
constaté lors de la réunion élargie
c'est le fait que les gens qui ont
commencé à se dire ceci pourrait être un
véritable problème ses rangs sang si
vous êtes dans un état américain en
floride ou romaine
par exemple si elle est une région qui
est demandé pour un élément vital de
l'économie
et bien ce serait dévastateur eh bien
les gens doivent se rencontrent cela
relève des intérêts de chacun eh bien
nous verrons ce qui se passe à la suite
des ces groupes de travail que nous
allons établir si le président
lorsque le président poutine a été
interrogé sur les droits de l'homme
il a dit que la raison pour laquelle ils
interpellent des dirigeants de
l'opposition il veut pas que des choses
celle-ci janvier se passe dans ce pays
il ne veut pas qu'il y ait des groupes
tels que blacklight mater dans son pays
qu'elle reprendrait que pour des gosses
à la réponse est celle que j'ai déjà
communiqué à savoir c'est une
comparaison ridicule
bon
comment ce que les criminels entre au
capital --via la sécurité et eu des
officiers c'est une chose
alors que des gens qui manifestent qui
disent vous ne permettez pas de
m'exprimer librement vous ne traitez pas
de faire abaisser de donc ce sont des
choses tout à fait différentes
steve around the writers monsieur le
président c'est le président poutine a
dit qu'il était satisfait de la réponse
que vous aviez lorsque vous avez dit
qu'il était un tueur pouvez vous nous
dire ce que vous avez dit il est
satisfait alors pourquoi est-ce que
j'abordais encore une fois cette
question lorsque vous lui parlez pensez
vous pouvoir avoir confiance en lui ce
n'est pas une question de confiance
c'est une question d'intérêts propres
est de la vérification de ses intérêts
propres
cela relève de cela donc virtuellement
comme toutes les personnes avec
lesquelles je réaliserai un accord au
président américain je ne dis pas j'ai
confiance en vous n'y a pas de problème
non on attend de voir ce qui s'y passe
donc il faut voir avec le résultat final
on n'est pas encore sûr
igor irait au liberty vous voulez vous
mettre à l'ombre pour vous pouvez me
voir vous savez qu'il y à des attaques
contre la société civile et contre la
presse libre et ces choses se
poursuivent en russie par exemple radio
free europe radio liberty la voix de
l'amérique et la chaîne de télé où je
travaille ont été déclarées agents
étrangers
il ya d'autres médias indépendants de
même
essentiellement nous sommes
forcé à partir après 30 ans après que le
président est elle si nous invitait donc
ma question est la suivante après vous
discussions avec le président poutine
d'après vous dans quelle mesure le
climat des médias va t'il s'améliorer en
russie je ne répondrai pas de cette
façon en termes d'amélioration du climat
des médias mais je dois dire à quel
niveau
est-ce que cela relève de ses intérêts
d'améliorer la réputation de la russie
parce que c'est un pays qui est contre
les valeurs démocratiques de liberté pas
de parole ce n'est pas une décision que
je peux prendre moi-même je ne pense pas
qu'il cherche à changer la nature d'une
société fermée ou modifier les actions
de son gouvernement
un qui estime qu'il a droit de faire ce
qu'il fait il s'agit d'une approche très
différente
je lui dis que j'ai lu pratiquement tous
les textes qu'il a écrits tous les
discours qu'il a prononcé j'ai lu
plusieurs bonnes biographies de lui
comme vous les avez lu vous même et je
lui
à signaler que la russie avait une
opportunité ce moment très court après
gorbatchev les changements drastiques
qui il avait la possibilité de se doter
d'un gouvernement démocratique
malheureusement cela a échoué et il y à
une course entre intellectuels russes
quant à déterminer quelle forme de
gouvernement il choisirait et comment le
choisir et il est sur la base de ma
conviction monsieur poutine a décidé que
la russie a toujours été une grande
puissance internationale lorsque la
russie était totalement unie en tant
qu'etat russie et pas sur la base une
idéologie qu'il s'agisse des trains des
commissaires de l'époque révolutionnaire
de la révolution russe et jusqu'à leur
situation actuelle je pense
il m'apparaît clairement je les dis et
lui le décider la russie se maintiennent
en tant que grande puissance c'est par
le biais de l'unification du peuple
russe
grâce à la force du gouvernement du
contrôle du gouvernement pas forcément
sur le plan biologique mais tout
simplement le gouvernement je crois que
c'est le choix qui a été fait et je ne
vais pas deviner si les choses auraient
pu se passer fondamentalement
différemment mais je crois que il veut
que la russie se maintiennent comme une
des grandes puissances mondiales
durant la conversation d'aujourd'hui
s'agissant de la ligne rouge cousein
établi aujourd'hui est-ce qu'une impasse
militaire possible sans ce qui concerne
les demandes de rançon et vous avez dit
une fois qu'il n'avait pas d'âme
le comprenez vous mieux ces deux
réunions
s'agissant de la rue n'en avons pas
parlé de réponse militaire
c'est
vous avez dit que les discussions en
tête à tête sans tirer de plan est
remplaçable
et vous avez parlé de la russie et de la
chine
vous avez dit à maintes reprises que
vous passerez probable en plus de temps
avec le passé en chic avec tout autre
dirigeant du monde donc le moment
viendra t'il où vous l'appellerait et
lui demanderez d'ouvrir la chine aux
enquêteurs de l'om est ce qu'ils
cherchent à savoir quelles sont les
origines du virus
oui nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps mais ne sommes pas amis de
long 4
c'est une question vous avez dit que
vous allez mettre la pression sur la
chine
vous avez adhéré aux communiqués du g7
indiquant que le g7 demandé à la chine
de s'ouvrir aux enquêteurs mais la chine
dit qu'elle ne veut pas faire l'objet d'
ingérence
il est bien l'impact c'est l'attitude
par rapport à la chine
la chine essaie de se projeter comme n
est un responsable et un pays en plein
essor
ils font beaucoup d'efforts pour montrer
qu'ils aient le monde avec l'aco viser
les vaccins et bien il y à certaines
choses qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
d'expliquer au monde
on voit les résultats est ce que la
chine souhaite effectivement arrivé au
fond de la cause du problème
comme je vous l'aï dit et au g7 et avec
le temps ce que nous devrions faire ce
que je vais m'efforcer de faire c'est de
radier le monde pour nous attaquer à ce
qu'ils constitueront les mécanismes
physiques disponibles pour détecter le
plus tôt possible la prochaine pause
amis et pour nous trouver doter des
moyens pourrait réagir le plus
précocement possible et ça se passera
[Musique]
voilà donc pour cette conférence de
presse de joe biden sur les bords du lac
léman elle a commencé à 19h20 il est
19h52 donc 22 minutes de conférence de
presse était plus court que vladimir
poutine on part tout de suite du côté de
genève pour retrouver olivier de
kerentrech olivier que faut-il retenir
de cette conférence de presse de joe
biden alors effectivement grégory un joe
biden s'était exprimée environ 45
minutes après son homologue russe
vladimir poutine
il a du bon il a dû donc pu répondre aux
questions ou aux affirmations de son
homologue russe en tout cas il a salué
cette rencontre un en préambule joe
gilgun qui l a qualifié ce sommet de
très direct il a précisé que rien ne
peut remplacer le dialogue en tête à
tête sur la qualité de ce dialogue et
cette rencontre il est revenu
injustement à la fin de sa première
prise de parole je vous propose de
l'écouter
il était important de se rencontrer en
personne pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
erreur aucune fausse représentation en
ce qui concerne ce que je souhaitais
communiqué j'ai fait ce que je voulais
faire premièrement j'ai identifié des
domaines de travail pratique pour le du
pays pour favoriser nos intérêts mutuels
pour nous mêmes et pour le monde
deuxièmement communiquer de manière
directe directement que les états unis
réagiront à des actions qui sont contre
nos intérêts vitaux aussi deux alliés et
troisièmement énoncer clairement quelles
sont nos priorités quels sont nos
valeurs
pourquoi ils entendent directement de ma
bouche et je dois vous dire que le la
tonalité de ses rencontres de plus de
quatre heures
l'ambiance était bonne positive oui donc
je baille donne effectivement qui a dit
qu'il n'était pas contre les russes
mais pour les états unis américaine
first donc pour joe biden le président
américain qui s'était également exprimé
sur plusieurs sujets comme la situation
au moyen orient plus précisément en
syrie où il a dit hey bien se mettre
d'accord sur des couloirs humanitaires
notamment en syrie un pour venir en aide
aux populations et puis il ya la sphère
navalni on en attendait on attendait des
déclarations sur ce sujet et bien le
président américain a dit clairement à
vladimir poutine qu'ils s'opposaient au
traitement réservé à alexeï navalni il a
également évoqué la biélorussie en
disant qu il s inquiétait de la
situation là-bas sur place autre sujet
abordé par le président américain celui
de la cyber sécurité
il a fait savoir à vladimir poutine que
certaines infrastructures ne devait
jamais être attaqué et il a précisé un
que les deux pays avaient mandaté des
experts afin d'encadrer les pratiques
écoutez j'ai parlé de cette idée que
certains a fracturé stratégique ne
doivent jamais être attaqué pour hâter
la ligne une des manières cyberéthique
aux autres je lui donnais une liste si
je m'abuse je n'ai pas demain au mois
mais il y est
16 entités spécifiques 16 entités
définit comme relevant de
l'infrastructure fondamentale des états
unis les six thèmes de l'eau ce principe
est fondamentale et cela doit être étayé
par la pratique les pays responsables à
prendre des mesures contre les criminels
qui prennent des mesures de rançons sur
leur propre territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus de
missionner des experts des deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compressions de ce
qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui leur origine dans l'un
ou l'autre de nos pays
alors voilà la cyber sécurité un qui a
été au coeur des échanges aujourd'hui
lors de cette rencontre entre joe biden
et vladimir poutine autre question
abordée celle de la sécurité nucléaire
concernant l'iran alors soucieux dossier
joe biden a affirmé que vladimir poutine
avaient convenu de s'investir avant afin
que l'iran ne se dote pas de l'armé
nucléaire et pion le disais on july dunn
est arrivé avant cette rencontre
en s'affichant un peu comme le porte
parole des droits de l'homme il l'a
affirmé à plusieurs reprises avant ce
sommet il est revenu un sur cette
posture ce soir lors de sa conférence de
presse écoutez le j'ai dit au président
poutine que mon agenda n'est pas contre
la russie ou contre qui que ce soit
d'autre
mon agenda et pour le peuple américain
pour lutter contre la queue vide
reconstruire notre économie
établir nos relations au tour du monde
avec nos amis et alliés et protéger le
peuple américain
cela constitue ma responsabilité en tant
que président je lui ai également dit qu
aucun président des états unis ne peut
être honnête envers le peuple américain
s'il ne parle pas aux efforts pour
défendre nos valeurs démocratiques se
porter garant pour les valeurs
universelles de la liberté dont sont
dotés les hommes et les femmes selon
nous cela relève de l'adn de notre pays
dont
que les droits humains figurant toujours
sur la table je lui ai dit il ne s'agit
pas simplement de s'en prendre à la
russie lorsqu'il viole les droits de
l'homme non cela relève de notre état de
profond comment est-ce que moi président
des états unis
pourrais-je m'abstenir de parler contre
les violations des droits de l'homme je
le lui dis et puis par ailleurs un joe
biden a également affirmé qu'il ne
croyait pas à une nouvelle guerre froide
avec son homologue russe voilà le
président américain qui a donc conclu
avec cette prise de parole ce sommet
entre la russie et les etats unis
aujourd'hui à genève alors d'autres
sujets bien évidemment ont été abordés à
la fois par vladimir poutine avant mais
également par joe biden on va y revenir
bien évidemment au cours de la soirée
notamment avec stéphanie de murs eu ce
soir très bon soit olivier bonsoir à
tous bienvenue pour deux heures
d'émissions consacrées évidemment
entièrement ce soir au sommet de genève
entre joe biden et vladimir poutine que
vous avez pu suivre depuis le début de
la journée en direct sur rt france
dispositif exceptionnel avec un aux
envoyés spéciaux de roncq olivier de
carantec que vous vais devoir antoine
claireaux également sur place